estoy de regreso con mi amigo winston
pero winston está triste porque lo hemos
dibujado en blanco y negro y eso es
aburrido vivimos en un mundo de color y
winston quiere tener todo tipo de
colores bueno tenemos un montón de
funciones que podemos usar para colorear
nuestros dibujos así que presta mucha
atención a este vídeo vamos a empezar
coloreando el fondo detrás de winston
arrastramos la función background arriba
observa que tiene un color dentro que
muestra el color que usará y lo cambia a
rojo brillante ahora él probablemente
quiere estar pasando el rato en el sol
así que vamos a elegir un lindo azul
cielo en su lugar hermoso es importante
saber que lo que hace la función
background realmente es dibujar un
cuadro grande coloreado sobre toda la
pantalla así que si lo arrastró al final
del programa de esta manera entonces va
a dibujar un cuadro grande sobre todas
mis figuras y ahora winston se fue esto
es algo absurdo vamos a traer a wilson
de vuelta arrastrando esto hacia arriba
ahora para colorear su cara digamos que
queremos que él sea un fantasma entonces
podemos usar esta función o phil que le
dice al programa que no use ningún color
para rellenar el resto de figuras
después de ésta
pero eso es un poco escalofriante y no
muy colorido así que voy a quitarlo
en su lugar vamos a colorear la cara
usando la función fill la función fill
significa básicamente usar el color para
todas las figuras que siguen
por eso la ponemos antes de él y así
afectará esta elipse es por eso que
todas las figuras se ponen rojas también
vamos a cambiar por
amarillo brillante ahora todo es
amarillo para cambiar el color de sus
ojos vamos a traer otra función film
arriba y vamos a elegir negro allí
para su boca queremos que sea de un
color diferente así que voy a traer otra
función film y la voy a poner justo aquí
antes de la boca y dejarla roja es lo
que está pasando
elegimos colorear de amarillo y se
colorea la elipse de la cara luego
establecimos colorear con negro y se
está usando ese color para las
siguientes dos figuras las hélices de
los ojos luego elegimos el color rojo y
se usa ese color para la siguiente leche
que es la boca y qué pasa si queremos
que la unicef sea de un color diferente
no podemos usar la función film porque
las líneas no pueden ser coloreadas pero
podemos usar la función strong porque la
línea tiene un borde y eso es
exactamente lo que esto cambia de color
arrastramos la función strong y la
hacemos rosa brillante muy bien
qué pasa si no queremos ningún borde
alrededor de su boca a su cara y sus
ojos podemos usar la función nos rock
para eso y ponerla al inicio de todo
ahora puedes ver que la hermosa cara de
winston no tiene bordes
todavía tiene una una hija de un hermoso
color rosa porque tenemos la función
stroke justo aquí pero todo lo que se
dibujó antes no tiene trazos
observa que es diferente en la función
nuestro es la primera función que vemos
que no tiene parámetros porque no hay
nada que definir ahí
o una cosa más qué pasa si queremos
hacer la ceja un poco más espesa tenemos
esta práctica función stroke wait y
stroke weight puede cambiar el tamaño de
los bordes podemos cambiarla y hacerla
gruesa gruesa a gruesa o si eso se ve
impresionante es todo lo que necesita
saber para colorear tus dibujos a ground
film no filtro nuestro castro weight
puedes tomar todas estas funciones de
aquí de la caja de herramientas de color
asegúrate de poner especial atención en
el orden de tus comandos y de
seleccionar los colores antes de la
figura que quieres colorear
allá vamos nuestro dibujo este coloreado
y winston está muy feliz
o sí